يتسلل هذا الشاب لالقاء القمامه على ضفاف
النهر مشهد يتكرر كثيرا والنتيجه اكوام من
القمامه يذهب بعضها الى اعماق النهر
مخلفات المواطنين تنضم لمخلفات المصانع
والمراكب والصرف الصحي تقارير تتحدث ان
الاعوام الماضيه شهدت زياده في معدلات
تلوث مياه نهر النيل ثلاثه اسباب رئيسيه
صرف صناعي صرف صحي صرف زراعي اي من
الثلاثه دول بيصل الى مياه نهر النيل
وترعه تتسبب في تلوث كبير في مياه النهر
هو لدول اسباب تلوث نهر النيل في الماضي
انما تم تقنينهم حاليا وتم ايقاف هذا
التلوث عدد من الوزارات المعنيه قامت
بالتنسيق مع شركات خاصه ومنظمات للمجتمع
المدني باطلاقه مبادرته لتنظيف النيل
الحمله تنطلق من محافظه القاهره والجيزه
وتهدف للوصول الى اسوان في الجنوب والهدفه
هو ازاله المخلفات ونشر الوعي المواطنين
حول اهميه الحفاظ على نظافه النيل
في 12 محافظه ايضا متواجدين بقوه تطوعيه
بتساعد نفسها في جمع المخلفات من مياه
النيل كجزء من دورنا في
المساعده في رفع الوعي باثار التغيرات
المناخيه هذه الحملات تتزامنه مع استعداد
مصر لتنظيم قمه قاب 27 للمناخ دي حاجه
احنا بيتهيا لي مش لازم ان احنا نبقى
بنعملها بس قبل المؤتمرات الشبيهه بكده دي
المفروض انها تبقى همم حاجات احنا بنعملها
على طول
والبيئه
يطالبون بيسني المزيد من القوانين
سواء كانوا افرادا او اصحاب المنشات
الناس يعني دلوقت كل واحد بيبقى معه في
النيل وربما
يتعلقوا بملابس تلوث نهر النيل هو في
القدره دي في تغيير ثقافه المواطنين في
التعامل البيئي مع شريان الحياه دي ملايين
المصريين احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره